Se nos dice que: "Todas las figuras
tienen la misma altura. Todas las figuras,
excepto B, tienen bases cuadradas". Esta
es una base cuadrada, este es un cuadrado,
este es un cuadrado y este es un cuadrado. "Todas
las figuras, excepto C, son prismas." Sí, C es una
pirámide, justo aquí. "Todas las figuras, excepto
D, están derechas." Puedes ver que D, justo aquí,
está un poco inclinado, o puedes verlo como
oblicuo. "Todas las figuras, excepto E, tienen la
misma área de base. La base de la figura E es una
homotecia de la base de la figura A, con un factor
de escala de 1.5." Muy bien, entonces nos dicen
que: "Si la figura A tiene un volumen de 28 cm³,
¿cuáles son los volúmenes de las otras figuras?"
Así que te invito a que pauses el video y veas si
puedes resolverlo por tu cuenta. Muy bien, ahora
trabajemos juntos en esto. Nos dicen que varias de
las figuras tienen la misma base, aunque la figura
E es diferente, y también nos dicen que todas las
figuras tienen la misma altura. Entonces, una
forma de pensar en el volumen es tratar con la
base y la altura. Para la figura A es bastante
claro; llamemos a esta área de aquí d minúscula,
que es el área de la base, y luego tenemos
cierta altura h, justo aquí, y sabemos que
multiplicar el área de la base por la altura
nos dará el volumen. Así que podemos decir que,
con base en la figura A, b • h = 28 cm³. Muy bien,
y ¿qué pasa aquí con la figura B? Bueno, es un
cilindro, ¿y cuál es el volumen de un cilindro?
Bueno, también va a ser la base por la altura,
entonces será el área de la base por la altura,
y si se preguntan ¿cómo es posible que el volumen
del cilindro sea igual al del prisma rectangular?
En realidad ese es el Principio de Cavalieri:
si ambas figuras tienen la misma altura y si en
cualquier punto de esa altura tienen la misma área
de sección transversal, entonces tendrá el mismo
volumen. Por lo que este volumen también va a ser
igual a la base por la altura. Permíteme escribir
que esta es la figura A, la figura B aquí,
el volumen de la figura B también será la b • h
que es igual a 28 cm³, el volumen de esto es igual
a esto y el volumen de esto es igual a esto. ¿Y
qué hay de la figura C? ¿Cuál es la fórmula para
el volumen de una pirámide? En otros videos ya la
hemos intuido y demostrado. Bueno, sabemos que el
volumen de una pirámide es igual a 1/3 b • h, y
sabemos que tiene la misma área de base que estas
otras figuras aquí, y tiene la misma altura,
entonces sabemos que la base por la altura son
28 cm³, por lo que el volumen de la pirámide es
1/3 • 28 cm³, que podemos escribir como 28 / 3
cm³ y también puedes escribir lo como 9 1/3 cm³.
Esto corresponde a la figura C. Ahora pensemos en
la figura D, lo haré por aquí. Bueno, para este
prisma inclinado, el Principio de Cavalieri nos
va a servir nuevamente, tendrá la misma fórmula
para el volumen que la figura A, será la base por
esta altura, así que podemos escribir que
el v = b • h, y ya sabemos lo que es eso:
la base por la altura será igual que en la
figura A, 28 cm³. Ahora pasemos a la figura E;
este es interesante porque tiene un área de base
diferente. ¿Cuál será el área justo aquí? Bueno,
nos dicen que la base de la figura E es una
homotecia de la base de la figura A, con un factor
de escala de 1.5, y ambas son cuadradas. Entonces,
el área de la base para la figura A es, digamos x
• x, entonces esta de aquí va a ser 1.5x • 1.5x.
Otra forma de pensar en esto es: sabemos que b,
que es el área de la base de la figura A, es igual
a x • x, ¿cuál es el área de la base de la figura
E? Bueno, será 1.5x • 1.5x que es igual a 1.5x²,
1.5x² es 2.25x², y ya sabemos que x², o x • x = b,
es igual a nuestra área base original en todas
estas otras figuras, por lo que el área de aquí
va a ser 2.25 • b -2.25 • b-, entonces 2.25 • b es el
área de la base justo aquí. ¿Y cuál es el volumen
de esta figura? El volumen va a ser el área de
la base, que es 2.25 por el área de las bases
de todas estas otras figuras, por la altura, que
es la misma, por h. Ahora sabemos que es b • h,
donde b es el área de la base de la figura A.
Sabemos que b • h es 28 cm³, entonces el volumen
para la figura E será 2.25 • 28 cm³, y no tengo
calculadora aquí, aunque puedo hacer el cálculo
a mano, pero creo que ya tienes la idea general:
tienes que multiplicar 2.25 • 28 para obtener el
volumen de la figura E, y eso es porque su base
ha sido escalada en cada dimensión por 1.5.